[Applause]
we
live a bit in the middle of nowhere the
nearest is 2 km away we are in the
village to see them a village of
250,300 inhabitants all the players
know each other
it's still a village like aging
with a will of the  mayor to really rejuvenate the
village by bringing families
to this village we have developed our
business we manufacture wooden glasses
skateboards
there was danger there
it makes five
associates from la rochelle de savoie
picard nor in  his others there to set up
the project etc and so we stayed we
weren't specially formatted on a
show is in town to succeed in setting
up a business
we were quite uninformed about our prejudices
we were given a building
for free during  three years with the
aim of really developing to test
our activity today we are in the
process of buying and seeing to enlarge
its area will be almost double the surface
for next year so  a nice
expansion what the 14
we are starting to hire people
really work at the cages it is
rather nice to say that we are creating an
activity in reality we know that this area
is rather economically devastated than
it usually
allows it allows to  well, he can
create a business with high
added value in the middle of the countryside
[Music]
I live in a yurt that I
made with my own hands with my friend who
joined me in July, a Parisian
who has relocated her  business and she
likes it too
I wanted to stay put to the test we have to
limit let's say but transport
I really wanted to do the
game of minutes on foot to be at work
there are a lot of things that happen  pass
to energize the region here it is the
companies clause today so there
are four five projects so like you
who like s and who are accompanied in
this case the values are the finan
ial support of the different actors depar
menta  national or European ux
for some it could not be done
that clearly the mayor is
very attentive to
the people they start we must not
let suffocate psychiatrist can bring back
more people in the village than
people live in the village it  is a
goal that it's like it's one day
maybe true what that
[Music]